un pomeriggio a tutti siamo qui per
parlare di porte per l'appunto se
parliamo di porto in particolare delle
porte automatiche scorrevoli le porte
che troviamo tutti i giorni al
supermercato che troviamo negli ospedali
negli aeroporti negli uffici dappertutto
porte che attraversiamo continuamente ci
troviamo davanti a queste porte cioè la
fotocellula ci sono le porte le ante di
vetro noi attraversiamo perché la
fotocellula riconosce la nostra presenza
e si aprono lo sappiamo andiamo a fare
la spesa andiamo ad attraversare queste
porte tantissime volte non lo diamo per
scontato se non sbagliamo l'orario il
posto aperto le porte si aprono e niente
noi abbiamo immaginato qualcosa di
particolare
abbiamo immaginato che queste porte
diventassero prendessero vita diciamo
diventassero corradi diverso nostra
opera d'arte una porta automatica e ce
la siamo immaginata immaginiamo quella
di un supermercato un supermercato
enorme un grande centro commerciale col
suo parcheggio questa porta la porta
dove andiamo attraversiamo amiamo fare
la spesa
ora che abbiamo in mente se l'avete in
mente lo togliamo togliamo il
supermercato e rimane la porta
togliamo tutto le macchine la gente che
sa far la spesa tutto quello che c'è
intorno rimane solo una porta automatica
bella
a noi piaceva così ci piaceva immaginare
una porta nel mezzo di un piazzale e
mezzo nel nulla
lì da sola come se avessero portato via
tutto e se la fossero dimenticato come
se fosse quella l'opera d'arte se fosse
una scultura e forse per capirla meglio
potremmo immaginarsela in piazza
maggiore a bologna qui ecco tanto per
essere un po campanilisti va beh
qualcosa di più esotico un deserto nel
deserto nel deserto una babele nel
deserto è una un'immagine che che ci
piace questa porta automatica che
vediamo tutti i giorni
all'improvviso la troviamo in mezzo al
deserto nella sabbia tra le dune il
caldo e possiamo immaginarci anche un
gruppo di turisti che sono in atto sono
lì sono nel deserto non si sa perché si
saranno persi e vedono questa porta
automatica e mezzo al deserto e e non è
un miraggio vanno vanno incontra questa
porta perché si sono stupiti del fatto
che ci sia una porta in mezzo al deserto
ma un po ci viene naturale perché siamo
abituati le tre versioni multi
nuovamente per cui anche se gli sembra
stupido perché questa porta nel mezzo
del niente
sì si può passare tranquillamente di
fianco e vediamo che non da nessuna
parte
gli viene naturale andarci di fronte
mettersi davanti e aspettarsi che si
apre però non si apre tanto tanto nel
deserto e questa scena succede possiamo
immaginarsela così come ce la siamo
immaginati noi in tanti altri posti
nello stesso istante sono come spuntate
queste porte e in altri posti
le immaginiamo all'aeroporto di brasilia
nella capitale del brasile nel piazzale
c'è una porta da sola e tutta la gente
non si vada avanti perché curiosa e non
si apre stessa scena mosca stessa scena
a hong kong
stessa scena in tante città del mondo si
sono queste porte così che non hanno
niente intorno che non danno da nessuna
parte ma un po di gente ci va per
curiosità
cerca di attraversarle ma non le apre e
quindi niente iniziano a bo si lamentano
ne parlano la posta non su facebook su
instagram ne parlano un po tutti dice
quella di bologna non ne parliamo il
carlino si scriverebbe un sacco di
articoli e tutti quanti ci lamenteremo
ma cos'è quel bagaglio in mezzo alla
piazza chi dichiara colta colpa del del
sindaco della degli antagonisti gli
antagonisti centri sociali o un'azienda
di porting vuole farsi pubblicità
fatto sta che non si sa perché c'è
questa porta non si sa tutti si
lamentano tutti se la prendono
perché qualcosa di strano qualcosa che
non ci che a cui non siamo abituati è
qualcosa che ti un po ci turba spesso
l'arte contemporanea fa questo non la
capiamo non ci piace e la critichiamo
però crea crea queste crea dei
ragionamenti intorno a volte se c'è dei
contenuti se c'è un messaggio e l'ho mai
vista stava lì stava libro immaginiamo
che sta lì perché ormai sta lì nessuno
riesce a toglierla consta più toglierla
che metterla quindi questo è il problema
più importante di questi tempi quindi la
si lascia lì o ci si abitua testa porta
quando arriva qualcuno a trovarci
diciamo no anzi sai lì da qualche anno è
buona e un po come diventa come le
banchine del civis stanno lì ci siamo
lamentati tutti quanti ne abbiamo dette
di tutti i colori il carlino ha venduto
un po più di giornali tutti quanti ce la
siamo presa però stanno lì a un certo
punto stanno lì le guardiamo ci
prendiamo che l'autobus civis non servo
sappiamo che cos'è a roster banchina ci
sono ecco la porta uguale sta lì e ci
interessa nella stessa maniera
non so se è più bello più brutto di una
banchina il cibo cioè se non che un
giorno passa passa una persona un
ragazzo che tu che arriva a bologna e
non aveva mai sentito parlare di questa
porta non aveva facebook non ha letto i
giornali non si sa dove forse arriva a
bologna
dentro la vera in piazza maggiore si va
incontro e la traversa semplicemente la
porta si apre e lui passa questa porta
non si era mai aperta per tanti anni e
tutta la gente in quel momento mentre
questo ragazzo semplicemente attraverso
una porta a un metro si ferma e riguarda
piazza maggiore in silenzio bloccata e
questo ragazzo si sente un po osservato
non capisce perché vi sono attraversato
una porta non c'era scritto non c'è
nessun divieto e piano piano tutti
quanti gli vanno incontro e pensano che
oggi finalmente la porta si sia aperta
finalmente l'anno aggiustata sono
riusciti ad aggiustarla eva provano
anche loro attraversarla ma non si apre
non riescono ad aprirla
allora vi prendono il ragazzo e lui la
pre loro si ritrovano e non si riescono
lui lo perquisiscono lo controllano non
ha nessun telecomando non ha nessuna
chiave semplicemente lui la apre e loro
noi così come la spada nella roccia non
sempre stata lì nessuno è mai riuscito
ma un giorno 16 riuscito e si
interrogano iniziano a e ognuno fa il
suo gruppetto e dice la sua arrivano i
vigili non si capisce cosa sta
succedendo ma siamo in piazza maggiore
no se questa scena e c'è qualcuno che ha
visto questa scena un po meglio di tutti
c'è qualcuno che dall'altra parte della
piazza in fondo la piazza ha visto tutto
ed è messo così qui avevamo ma so quante
quest e è un humor l 1 mar el
chiaramente lì in fondo alla piazza ha
visto tutto non dice niente ha visto la
scena cruenta pensa e ha però già visto
qualcosa l'ha visto la lista è lui a una
teoria perché come ci insegna danilo
masotti marella hanno sempre una teoria
però questa volta è un po strane una
teoria che lui sa perché ha visto che
questo ragazzo ha fatto qualcosa che gli
altri non hanno fatto e lui ne è
convinto perché l'ha visto tutte le
volte che lui la prima faceva qualcosa e
gli altri no però un po è un po strana
el un marello alla sua dignità e non
vuole dirla subito così se se la tiene
un po per sé mentre c'è tutto questo
capannello intorno alla porta sempre
questa porta automatica lui si avvicina
senza dire niente a nessuno e si mette
davanti e fa quello che ha fatto il
ragazzo sa fa un sorriso a porta si apre
e lui passa e tutti guardano lo marello
e lui è il suo momento di celebrità ymer
da piazza maggiore finalmente può dire
la sua teoria questa volta alle prove
funziona lui sa come si apre sta
benedetta porta
bastava pochissimo e tutti glielo
chiedono e lui dice un sorriso passava
da sorriso quello che il ragazzo aveva
che gli altri non avevano è un sorriso
quello che romanello non sapeva è che in
realtà non solo quella porta si era
aperta quella di piazza maggiore si
erano aperte tutte tutte quelle che
abbiamo nominato e le altre che non
abbiamo nominato quella nel deserto
quella mosca quella brasilia si erano
aperte tutte contemporaneamente perché
sono tutte collegate tra di loro per cui
vedendone aprirsi una sappiamo che da
qualche parte nel mondo qualcuno ha
sorriso e con un sorriso le aprì tutte
se questa era quello che volevamo fare è
l'idea che ti ha spinto a realizzare
questa porta che si apre semplicemente
con un sorriso e
c'è da dire che in brasile ci siamo
quasi riusciti ma non ce l'abbiamo fatta
a mosca l'abbiamo portata ma solo per un
po state rito e anche di tornante non è
rimasta lì russi l'hanno aperta al
sorriso però poi rimasta non è non è
rimasta lì negli altri posti ci stiamo
lavorando e anche per quello che la
raccontiamo qui perché abbiamo bisogno
dell'aiuto di di chi vuole aiutare gli
artisti di chi vuole aiutare un progetto
perché gli piace perché gli sembra utile
perché secondo noi è una cosa importante
per noi per noi importante questo
progetto finora ce n'è solo una qualcuno
che ci ha dato ascolto
esiste una permanente proprio qui a
bologna ma non è in piazza maggiore
no è in una chiesa alla fine di via
zamboni davanti alla pinacoteca per cui
se uno vuole andare a fare un sorriso
può andare alla chiesa di santa maria
maddalena è una bellissima chiesa è uno
arriva contento e le si spalanca il
portone per cui invece di entrare a
destra oa sinistra come entriamo di
solito in chiesa possiamo entrare dal
portone centrale e quando anche tutte le
altre saranno collegate in internet
presenti aprendo quella porta sarà un po
come entrare in tutte le altre porte
come essere nel mondo
il nostro pensiero è stato non solo non
è un gioco non vogliamo fare un giochino
per un negozio di dentisti che si apre
se tu sorridi non hanno chiesto se non
si interessa la pubblicità di un
dentifricio ci interessa che secondo noi
potrebbe essere la porta dell'italia nel
mondo potrebbe essere un modo per
entrare dovunque noi siamo in un box
potrebbe essere come l'italia potrebbe
essere apposta alla porta d'europa se
fosse in tutte le piazze d'europa e
saremo tutti collegati da un sorriso
quando ne vedremo una di queste aprirsi
così da sola senza nessuno davanti
sappiamo sapremo che da qualche parte
qualcuno sta facendo un sorriso questo è
quello che ci interessava perché artisti
sensazione in testa una cosa noi avevamo
avuto quest'idea lo volevamo fare sì
perché perché in un mondo in cui
costruiamo solo muri per tenere lontano
gli stranieri gli altri
costruiamo barriere reti chiudiamo le
porte non sorridiamo non salutiamo
nessuno abbiamo solo paura ergiamo
sempre più distanze tra tra noi e gli
altri che sono come noi
una porta che si apre perché perché si
apre con un sorriso secondo noi è un
messaggio forte messaggio importante che
ci va di di fare per cui per cui basterà
questo per cui se domani
nadia antonello e paolo ghezzi grazie
grazie